Xin Chào mừng bạn đến với kênh tin học
gỗ Bảo Nam Vlog video ngày hôm nay đâu
còn em Plus chia sẻ với bạn cách xóa
bảng chấm nhốt xóa đường kẻ của bạn
trong Word
a đối với các phiên bản gốc khác nhau
bạn thực hiện hoàn toàn tương tự nhau và
trong video này đỗ vào nam và lúc đang
dùng buốt 2021
A và trong video này Đỗ Bảo Nam vào lúc
sẽ chia thành 2 phần
bạn thân thứ nhất xóa bảng trong Word
minh chia sẻ với bạn cách để xóa bạn ở
đây giả sử như mình đã chuẩn bị sẵn hai
bản ở đây thì các cách xóa bảng trong
Word và thực hiện như sau Cách thứ nhất
bạn sẽ dùng phím back up trên bàn phím
bước thứ nhất bạn rê chuột qua cái bản
cần xóa khi đó bạn sẽ nhìn thấy có một
cái cần hình 40 tên ở góc trên bên trái
của bạn và bạn chỉ cần click chuột trái
vào cái thân này để cho bạn ạ
Uh cho nó bớt gay bạn nhấn phím back up
trên bàn phím bạn nhớ là nhấn phím back
kết chứ không phải là phím đen ít như
vậy mình đã xóa xong cái bản thứ nhất
tiếp theo mình sẽ sang cách xóa bản thứ
2 đó là thao tác Thiên cái Menu
thi các bước bạn thực hiện thì sau
bước thứ nhất Vạn Xuân Kích chuột vào
một tô nào đó nhưng mạnh hoặc bạn cũng
có thể chọn bảng như cách rồi Ví dụ ở
đây mình chỉ cần chọn một ô nào đó
gì nó vất từ nay bạn Click vào layer
trên menu
mà chọn đen ít ít
bài tiếp theo bạn kích vào dòng decibel
để xóa như vậy mình đã xóa xong bản like
a
a tiếp theo mình sẽ sang phần thứ hai
xóa đường kẻ của bạn kéo nhớt
giả sử như trên màn hình bạn nhìn thấy ở
đây mình có một Vàng đơn giản như thế
này vàng này mình sẽ trình bày ở dưới
một cái file word đề xuất một cái gì đó
hoặc là một cái đơn tin nào đó chẳng hạn
thi để chia văn bản ra thành 3 cột mình
có thể tạo bảng cho nó Anh hello bạn
phải xóa các cái đường bazơ của bảng đi
thì các bước để xóa các đường kẻ hàng
bạn thực hiện như sau
bước thứ nhất bạn mỗi đem cái bảng cần
xóa nợ thẻ ở đây để bonheur bạn chỉ cần
rê chuột qua mảnh Sau đó bạn sẽ thích
vào ai cần 40 Tên như trên màn hình
ạ sau đó Bước thứ hai bạn và thắp hôm
đi tìm đến thuốc fatig grab
A và Vâng Click vào của anh cần đó là
Order
Madrid vào cái hình mũi tên xuống
chọn level như vậy bạn đã xóa các cái
đường Paul của bạn hay nói cách khác là
bạn đã xóa các đường kẻ khoảng xong
mình sẽ xuống để bạn nhìn thấy con hơn
và như vậy trong nội dung với đâu rồi
đốt vào nam và đốt người chia sẻ nhanh
mạnh cách xóa bảng trong Word Hoa xóa
đường kẻ của bạn trong watch
Nếu bạn có những câu hỏi cơ động hỗ trợ
bạn hãy comment chỉ tiêu thế giới nước
này Cảm ơn bạn đã theo anh cứ đâu Xin
chào và hẹn còn này bạn ở các video tiếp
theo
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích bạn nhấp chuột vào nay và chia sẻ
video để ủng hộ Đỗ bà Nam với ấp Đông
thai Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ bạn
nam lúc bạn anh nhấp chuột vào nút đăng
ký và chọn hình Trung Khi
nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và nhận thêm
các video hữu ích từ đỗ bà Nam vào lúc
Xin cảm ơn các bạn
Ngoài ra bạn có thể tìm kiếm trên Google
với từ khóa Đỗ bà Nam Vlog
và truy cập website đô Bảo Nam vip.com
hoặc kênh YouTube nếu bà Năm blocks để
xem thêm các video gũi như thủ thuật máy
tính tay Producer
cách sử dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint vân vân và bạn có thể truy
cập Website là đỗ bà Nam vào lúc chúng
con để cập nhật những bài viết đối mới
nhất
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và
hẹn gặp mày bạn ở các video tiếp theo